it's every every time you see like a
turn-ons list you know like from a woman
it's like I love cookies and puppies and
long walks in the beach like who was
actually walking on the beach like who
takes too long how long do we have yeah
can we have a short walk the beach is
right here goes to the water yeah I
didn't hear the guys on d-day when they
invaded Normandy hey well we got it was
pretty terrible but we could get along
well combination exactly yeah yeah and
then running on the beach is brutal
you know Baywatch they shot everything
at like 5:00 a.m.
dude that was it is it easier to run on
the beach no I just live did they'd have
to shoot things there's no people on the
beach but they said the water was
freezing that's poor Baywatch
wonder one rated show in the world i
watch the hell out of that you know
you're gonna masturbate to something me
and it's true that Pamela oh yeah I feel
like that's a so that's like a telling
thing about men
you're either into Pamela Anderson or
you're not you're into panel I am I'm
gonna gotta be honest this is I'm not
the the silicon and the the blonde and
the bleach yeah not my thing
I just it's like a Barbie I would take
the Yasmine Bleeth back before she went
you know right I would take her over the
patients and some things going on here
like some wrinkles and maybe some well
you know it happens you know after a
while but the young Yasmine I'll take
that over a fam Anderson mm-hmm Nicole
Eggert is the shorter and yes use on
Charles in Charge board I love that show
yeah oh you got a match
so we're sitting on your futon right now
that doesn't mean I'm sitting in like a
puddle of urine ah yes but it's dried
it's dry well that's still not very
sanitary it's actually more oh you're in
the head area yeah you don't maybe know
urinate I don't drown myself in urine
but uh I'm in the year really well pig
in a poke right I guess a pig's they
don't have fingers ain't nothing to poke
I think what you meant to say was a pig
in a mud Pig and pig a pig in the mud
big and [ __ ] pig and [ __ ] that's what
this for the folks I better you know
what I love is a pig in a blanket
oh yeah that'll shoot your cholesterol
through the window not the food
literally oh man that's something to
think about
so you know yeah I've worked with his
Eskimo guy no no you forgot about that
project you were on he's like introduce
you were doing stand-up in the Anchorage
Sun what happened he was a he's Eskimo
blood like he's in any which his parents
are Inuits but he got out of it there
are weird people like he's a normal guy
now be talking about his parents and
stuff and you know they live in sub-zero
temperatures they see daylight like
three months out of the year their
houses are made of ice you know but I
think the worst part about it is that
kiss rubbing the nose yeah lady I just
killed a whale for you what are you
gonna rub my nose in come on this is
worse than like dinner and a movie I
wonder what their [ __ ] are like yeah
yeah what is what is there a [ __ ]
that's right - ass cheeks touching you
it just seems awfully we're human beings
we live in this awful place let's let's
just make it oh did you know this man
Eskimos there were 47 different ways to
say [ __ ] I wish I lived somewhere warmer